yo what's good I'm Jazzy you can catch
me on the bootleg kale podcast
bootleg cat podcast man special guest in
here
are you the first artist on love records
yeah for sure Jazzy is here what's
happening
now I can't say the name of your uh EP
yeah
because there is an n word you can say
but you could say it for homies okay
okay you can say for homies freak son
swimming free game for the homies did
you get any bike pushed back for the
label when you uh named it that that's
why I love puff because he's like just
run it because you know it's because
it's about us it's like FUBU you know
what I'm saying like like like
now now Walmart owns FUBU by the way
shout out to the FUBU guys well I think
Walmart owns it well that's crazy I
might be wrong about it cashed out yeah
but you know you go to FUBU get Walmart
yeah Walmart yeah that's crazy but now
the EP is dope um for you like uh you've
had a pretty crazy Journey Through the
music industry give everybody kind of
like a rundown on like
because you're obviously an amazing
Rider
um what is kind of like your history in
the music game you've had it come up
that's pretty crazy from working with
Timberland and now working with Diddy
like how did you get started
man long story short
um I'm from Memphis Tennessee shout out
to Memphis on fire right now Memphis is
going crazy but you don't say Mercy I
don't say I'm gonna tell you why my mama
I my mama was an English teacher oh okay
okay so she helped me like now that I
look back now that I'm older
like she really helped me because I I'm
country but not like my cousins yeah
everyone from Memphis says Mercer you
know yeah music
[Laughter]
I can say it but I I know how not to say
it right right right right right your
mom was like no yeah you gotta train
yourself it's like a muscle you gotta
work on it so I was you know saying my
mama like really helped me with that I
used to hate that too though right
but but now I appreciate it but um but
uh so pretty much I was working at the
studio called Trap House in Memphis in
Memphis DJ Lil Larry who trap house he
had Trap House shoot maggots and he's
like he's Yo Gotti right hand man and um
I have met these this guy well who's
actually young dolls producer rest in
peace well he had this crew to caught
the machine and they knew this this guy
wisdom from he was from Memphis but he
lived in VA with Timberland okay and I
was in school and um
he I met him and he was like uh yo this
the studio got raided I was depressed I
was like I don't know what I'm about to
do
then they called me to come to Miami to
work with this this artist that Tim was
just you know gave to whiz to work on he
needed a writer right flew me down there
and I met Tim I met Missy and I was
always been there for a week and I ended
up staying like five years bro from like
five years yeah it's from 2012 to like
I just moved 28 well it's not just moved
but I just I moved here in 2018. it
sounds like it wasn't a long time ago
but that was actually five years ago so
whole time you were just in Miami just
cooking up with Tim Yeah well yeah just
the flower I wasn't even really cooking
up like me and Wiz had out like we would
like when when Tim wasn't working like
three in the morning when he would leave
we would just you'd have the studio so
we would be like we would be just
literally I was just the kid the little
20 year old kid just walking around the
studio meeting Wayne seeing everybody
like Polo I met little I met the whole
Cash Money cool bird right and that's
kind of how I did put some resp I put I
did that song Respect put some respect
when you mentioned my name for Birdman
because I was just at the studio you
know it's crazy so yeah I was just I was
just there being just a legit just like
literally just in China yo you need what
you need what you need what you need
what you need you know what I'm saying
cause like picking up the lingo as you
saw you just said jit which is yeah yeah
it's a Florida thing for real like swear
like for real so like I'd be saying I'm
from Memphis by way of Miami because
like I feel like I spent like the years
where you grow up like your 20s
formative years in Miami yeah what like
I really learned like what are some of
your uh writing credits that you've uh
picked up over the years
it's so funny like that one um Birdman
respect because I I it's so funny I was
I heard that story she was like dang I
really did that that's hilarious because
you know he did that uh Breakfast Club
yeah iconic interview that's why I did
it uh
I did
um Monica just write for me with with
Lil Wayne No I did
Chris Brown discover Jacquees you summer
Walker body off of you
um
goodness gracious well I got a brain
fart oh lemonade uh Donald and internet
money yeah the internet money smash
thank you bro you wrote that hook I
wrote the whole song you wrote the whole
song yeah it was my song you can go to
Spotify listen to my version really yeah
if you type in Jazzy lemonade like and
then you know and then they changed the
beat and then they made it what it was
crazy I did um Mr right now uh 21 Savage
and Drake yeah I did ass and titties 21
Savage
so when you like okay because like we
look at 21 Savages like you know a
rapper's rapper when you like help write
on a song for him is it the hook is it
just the hook hell no I don't write
verses okay at all like I don't like
that and and it's a disrespect to even
like like rappers like 21 of them if
they hear a burst they don't they won't
play it that's good so like I don't even
want to shoot myself in the foot to try
to even give like you know what
I'm saying I said yeah I stick with the
hook yeah I know what worked for me you
know what I'm saying like how I know how
to play the game bro I ain't gonna even
try to write your verses but the hook
the idea like you know saying structure
Mr right now is a big one too that was a
great one lemon I feel like lemonade is
like
that's gotta be like I was wondering
five six seven times platinum or
something yeah and what's so funny when
I did Old Town Road bro like I ain't
gonna lie when when it was going so
crazy you did Old Town really I co-wrote
on it you did yeah I did Billy Ray
Cyrus's version
and so that junk changed my life and um
it was so funny
um I was scared of it bro cause it was
so big and I was like you know
gonna try to put they're
gonna try to put me in a in a box as a
pop gimmicky writer right so I was
scared of that bro like it was going it
was going number one and I was like okay
I'm happy but like
this ain't me and then I promise you
next the next year's lemonade came out
and then and it like everything yeah it
made me be like okay you can do
everything yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying because like I was
really I was really really really scared
of that what was it like because at the
time that remix that's gotta be this is
the biggest song in the world at the
time and then the remix comes out makes
it bigger yeah
do you like know much about Billy Ray
Cyrus before you write the book because
he's like you know it's a country Legend
I'm from Memphis right so you know like
we like you know we next door to
Nashville you know what I'm saying we
ain't nothing like Nashville but we next
door to it so I mean and then I used to
like I always say I used to be in love
with Miley Cyrus I used to watch Hannah
Montana I was still in love with Miley
Cyrus what's happening Molly might be
out there for you I would love it she
got a voice I could she got a voice yeah
she's a man like what's up bro she doing
like when she talks like if you heard
her do like interviews like she was on
Joe Rogan she's gone she got a voice she
got a scratchy ass deep voice they don't
stop nothing I gotta scratchy deep voice
so I guess it'll be all right yeah her
voice is like come on like what was
remember when Gloria was talking about
how she moans when she's getting like oh
no I can't imagine like uh oh no her
voice ain't that deep that's wow but
yeah I definitely was aware of uh Billy
Ray Cyrus you know what I'm saying so
like were you nerd like you were kind of
were you nervous outside of like being
boxed in were you just nervous like damn
like this is a big look like no I was
nervous about being boxed in bro I just
do you weren't worried about just like
nah man I ain't care about nothing else
but just being boxed in I just was like
I hope these folks don't think that that
I'm this type of writer right you know
what I'm saying like just I don't want
people to think that I'm like
you know because I'm I'm really I really
can make substance right and like not
that I'm saying otaro was a substance
because look what Leonard's X did was
incredible with that song right so I'm
not like jabbing you know what I'm
saying but I just know like I'm a like
I'm a songwriter who really loves lyrics
and like who really loves like putting
thought into like
um like feeling and like right not
trying to control the algorithm that was
very that was like he controlled the
algorithm with that song like he's just
crazy that song was everywhere one of
the biggest songs ever crazy insane so
for you like because I I've seen it
happen with other artists where they're
like really big and like kind of
perceived as a writer it's worked out
for other artists where they pop as an
artist yeah but um I know it's like is
it tougher for you to like
do you do you have to shake the writer
like because people see you as a writer
sometimes and they might not see you as
an artist because I've seen it happen
with other writers of course it's a
little like like I mean it's probably a
gift and a curse you already got your
foot in the door obviously but yeah it
was so crazy
like I used to have a lot of a Nars call
me before I dropped this project like yo
work working my art like now
it's quiet I think people like they kind
of scared to like hit me right because
to work right because they know that I'm
really
I'm really focused on my artist thing
but what's so what I'm blessed about is
every artist that I work with bro like I
got a connection with these folks I can
text little baby I can text William
right now and be like twin what you
think about this I could taste Coco
Jones and be like yo I got this song
what you think right like I'm really
blessed like literally like Chloe just
text me a few days ago like yo can I can
I work on that song that you that you
sent me I'm like please go ahead like
right so I'm so blessed that like like I
can text these artists you know what I'm
saying I don't need like I don't have to
like
go to anybody and I don't mind I'll mess
with you know if like you want to do
sessions but like like I look at how
like I sell you I look at how the dream
and Missy did it like the dream didn't
stop writing for people he wrote he was
selectable who he wrote for but he still
got Rihanna hits he still got Beyonce
hits you know Missy exactly bro so like
I don't have to stop one thing to do the
other um I feel like when I step out
when I want to drop my music I'm in my
bag yeah you know what I'm saying like
but yeah I feel like I always been I
meet whatever I do as an artist or as a
songwriter like right I didn't want to
be no Ghostwriter like I want I'm a star
right like when I walk in that room as a
songwriter I'm a star when I walk in
that room as an artist I'm a star no
matter what yeah yeah you know what I'm
saying you mentioned uh hanging out with
Missy how were you guys because she's
one of the goats like I love missing uh
do you guys build a relationship super
super we built a really great
relationship I don't talk to her as much
now but she me up like I'm proud of you
right congratulations but um
yeah now like Missy taught me a lot she
really taught me
she taught me how to like when I was
staying with her she didn't have an
engineer so I had to learn how to record
myself
I had to learn how to light you were
like staying with Missy Elliott yeah I
was at a crew like in Atlanta we stayed
with her for a few few weeks then um I
went to Jersey and we stayed with her
and like literally she she made us do
this master cleanse for like seven days
and we was like starving she made me
start my weight loss journey I lost like
60 pounds yeah she did a great job not
herself yeah she did yeah so like so
yeah like Missy like she really she
really taught me how to like get the
work done like she don't go out she
works and she worked like she broke and
I was broke and I'm trying to go outside
right and she's like nah take your ass
in this free Studio that I got upstairs
you got a free Studio upstairs why the
hell you want to go outside right like
when somebody like like break it down
like that like you broke like why
you wouldn't go outside I was like
that's some real best she
could have told me bro you said you just
did a show at sobs in New York which is
obviously a legendary venue what was
that like that man that's like
sobs that was the probably the most
amazing energy that I ever got from like
because you know New York like New York
is tough for sure it's tough yeah it's
like it could go either way go either
way bro and it went the right way and
and like no puff puff didn't pull up and
I'm really glad he did right you know it
would have been like he would you know
it would have been like more about puff
right right right in New York and I'm
and I held my own yo what's good man we
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our good Folks at my bookie that's
right man NBA season is uh winding down
playoffs are going down so many ways you
can get money you could bet on who you
think's gonna win the finals you can get
your prop bets per game uh we are
finally down to the final eight right
now uh my sons ain't looking good at the
time of recording not looking good uh
look go to mybookie.ag right now sign up
I've been gambling on my Boogie for over
10 years so listen come and join me
let's get this money together
mybookie.ag when you use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up use that promo
code you're going to get that deposit
bonus that deposit bonus is craziest the
sign up bonus you get and uh not only
are basketball football which is
starting to creep up on us baseball's
back MLB baseball man all season long
you get this money plus they got the
online casino if you're into craps
Blackjack roulette slot machines
whatever it is go to mybookie.ag right
now use that promo code bootleg and get
that free deposit bonus that's how we're
doing things all right also I want to
give a big shout out to the homies of
King Palm man these are our new sponsors
at King Palm now this is the thing about
these King Palms man these things right
here
ah natural natural leaves free of
tobacco and additives the only thing I
smoke out of and what's dope is they got
these other ones right these uh this is
one of their more popular items right
here
great flavor
these are the leaf rolls they hold a
gram each and they got the terpene fused
tips which means you squeeze and you pop
the tip while you're smoking your flour
and you get a little burst of flavor
these are the peach pineapples
um they got the energy drink flavor they
got blue blueberry watermelon all kinds
of man
um so what's dope if you go to
kingpom.com and use the promo code
bootleg cab right now you're gonna get
half off half off half off kingpom.com
tobacco free
natural
raps all right and also don't forget if
you're in a I don't know wherever you're
at go to 7-Eleven they got them your
local smoke shop one of the most
successful uh businesses in the game
when it comes to the all-natural Leaf
the most successful no tobacco no
nicotine just natural Leafs to stuff
your flour in and in case you did not
know they also have
whatever size King Palm this is
this is a giant Leaf wrapped around yeah
wrapped around some premium can I buy
shout out to uh King pump go follow one
more time kingpound.com promo code
bootleg Kev say 50 off let's get back to
the interview right and it just showed
me like nobody missed that like they was
there for me that's obesity and I I
ain't gonna front though like they got I
told I thought they gotta fix sobs up
though a little bit they gotta it's been
like that they got it they gotta sweat
they gotta do something bro like it's
SOB's sobs ain't gonna change huh it's
just it's just sobs man like Walmart
Walmart is gonna be Walmart I ain't
gonna put no chandeliers nah yeah sobs
is you know it's the this is this it's
kind of like that venue you gotta hit in
New York on your way up and yeah you
just gotta take it what would you
amazing though I'll do it again right
now I was gonna say how it because
because you were saying a bunch of dudes
showed up to the show yeah
um because I do feel like I love that
too I love that it was a lot of guys in
there how would you say your fan base is
like are you noticing like a lot more
women or men like because it feels like
you're because you kind of as a as a
lesbian woman I feel like you're like
when I listen to your I kind of
like I can relate to this because
you're talking about you know what I
mean like with girls you know
what I'm saying so it's like you know I
feel like it's a relate related you kind
of relatable on both aisles thank you
thank you so you're kind of checking a
lot of boxes like and I feel like other
female artists um on the r b side might
not thank you again that means a lot
because I'm telling you bro that was a
different crowd like it was a lot a lot
of girls a lot of girls that was and
then it was like and then in the middle
it was like couples
and then in the back it was the hood
and like it did to the
left side it was like like the like in
the VIP section it's the baddies you
know they want to send the VIP section
then you had your gay couples two you
know guys on guys and it was just
everybody was just like I never like I
really didn't know what my crowd was I
was just like it was crazy like in the
front it was just all girls but like you
know right I really just
I love that that my crowd is what it is
you know what I'm saying and I
appreciate that even in Atlanta like
I was like oh yeah like it's it's it's
not just one thing and that means a lot
to me because like it looked like like
the guys was filming and guys was in
there I'm like damn bro like that made
me feel that made me feel uh feel good
and appreciate it because
um you know you just want everybody not
to feel like yo oh she's a gay artist
she's for gay she's for the gays no like
I ain't funny I don't even I'm not for
the gays I'm for the women and I'm for
the that's why I sung swimming
free game for like for everybody
but everybody you know yeah I like no I
couldn't say for the gays
I'm for everybody yeah
for the games for everybody you know but
like I love that
um for you like uh you know obviously
Diddy because Diddy we we think back to
what was it about a year ago you said R
B's dead
and then for him to launch love records
and have a amazing like I mean you're
making just dope records thank you so
much remind me of like uh
the r b that's kind of been missing you
know thank you we get a lot of like the
alternative r b vibey but I'm like
where's that arm Basin that I grew up on
you know so for you uh do you feel any
pressure like being
signed to the guy who said rmb's dead
nah no pressure cause you got to back
that up you know like and what's so
amazing nobody nobody online was said
nothing crazy like
and I'm not even a person who like looks
at comments but like literally nobody
said anything about that r b is dead
like oh oh she didn't live up to it like
no I didn't see not one like well I mean
I think did he knew what he was doing he
probably was like yeah R B's dead but I
got the answer but the thing is yeah I
mean like r b is here and it's alive and
it's crazy I think R B is in a great
Arby's in a great space it's just a
certain RB like they don't like like the
up tempos like summertime jams like what
happened to the loomy D's and like the
uh oh Jagged Edge what's the weather you
know what I'm saying and that's why
we're replaying that shit's gone for
sure yeah no but it's not we bringing it
back that's why we got replay right
that's why we got commotion and that's
even like the Army groups yeah r b
groups yeah no well Flo from from the UK
yeah they are they just had a show the
episode with Missy yeah exactly fell
from the UK is like the UK is up is like
actually on us right now on the
Army they're on us when it
comes to a lot of things with music I
ain't gonna lie to y'all they're they're
so Progressive but um shout out to my
boy Saint a Uptown who who got flow but
like literally like that's what I want
to do I want to bring back summertime
box you know what I'm saying that's why
I'm listening that's why I like replay
has that feeling that commotion and like
I want to even alone like you can play
alone in the club I've heard of DJ speed
it up a little bit and it's still got a
bot where you're like that's what I'm
talking about like still got a hip-hop
vibe to it for you
um obviously you putting out an EP is
the album still being worked on man
listen bro I'm almost done with the
album literally bro like I'm I literally
just texted puff today like yo I'm about
to put the project on I'm gonna we
transfer you what I got so far let's
play let me know your thoughts I want
you to listen to it digest it and you
know because I like it's a lot of things
that I want to like fix up and clean up
but this this album is about to be like
I didn't have no features on the last
album on the EP because I want to hold
my own my own artists to feel like I'm
trying to use them right but like I'm
I'm going for the I'm going I'm going
I'm trying to go for anyone I want I'm
not scared I'm asking everybody well I
keep hearing about also too like uh
this Diddy album
A lot of people have heard it's so good
uh yeah obviously he put the Bryson
tiller single out last year yeah
um are you helping him a lot with that
yeah I'm I'm down there like a r in the
project I heard it's like a DJ Khaled
Type R B album kind of it is that's
that's a beautiful damn that's hard
that's exactly what it is he's rapping
on it though like but definitely like
like he is like what's the uh Circus the
burner
he's the ring master
yes he's like the ring Master yeah he's
like boy and I'm saying and like it is
so freaking good
good I am not the project like as far as
like
taking like every song like taking it
off putting songs on it he's trusting me
what I be having to like
I'll like if I leave for a week he'll
put a song on him like puff take that
off no Take that off like right I gotta
like be around here 24 7 because it's
always somebody else around you know
what I'm saying but like this man is
just a genius move like puff is like
scary this dude's ear the dude's ear is
just I just don't like and he also you
his work ethics insane his work
ethic is nasty it's kind of I like he's
a little OCD
you know and I'm not I'm not an OCD like
person when it comes especially when it
comes to music like
like if you hear my chain rattling in
there it's just gonna stay in there I
don't care if you hear the chair every
time I like if you're recording vocals
or something yeah I don't care about
right I like I'm just not right I like
that yeah they're almost like yeah no
for sure it's good kind of character yes
I agree you know what I'm saying but
like you know I'd be like stop you don't
overcook like you can cook but don't
overcook your like you know what
I'm saying so I'm trying to teach and I
think that's the difference between the
90s and today is like the 90s they took
so they took a long time with everything
that they did for sure they took a long
time but like you know there's a there's
a way like we can kind of like integrate
your your way and then yeah yeah and
like you know don't overcook it it's
just for you are you like uh are you are
you straight just going in cutting the
melody first and filling in the lyrics
I'm a freestyle of a show I I like
the way Pluto do it is the same way I do
it like literally I go in there and
freestyle I come I'll go out there sit
with my engineer comp The Melodies and
then I'll be like yo I don't even write
anymore I'd be like play the line line
for line just hit and so sometimes that
needs to be the way the most yeah people
are doing it that's how I write songs
for anybody though like anybody and it's
so hard because like when I'm writing
for artists they'd be like send me the
lyrics I'm like damn right now I got it
right now I gotta listen back and oh
it'd be so hard like that's the worst
part of the whole thing is having to
write it when they be like send me the
lyrics I'm like uh
try to write these down in the first
place yeah bro cause like you be just
because I do like four songs a night
five songs a night like write a whole I
can do like five songs like whole songs
damn and so like after that after that
third or fourth you don't even be wanna
like you being such a the mood you know
you don't want to stop and write these
lyrics down bro that's just be like
stopping the process but but it is
summertime if you're dealing with elect
erectile dysfunction Ed if you will
maybe you got stress at work maybe
you're tired of looking at the same
chick
maybe you just need a little pep in your
step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits and uh it has the same
active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it promise you that
Bluetooth also is uh incredible because
not only does it come in the blue
chewable flavor with the same active
ingredient as vibrancy house but it also
has a mint chewable flavor which is the
same active ingredient as Levitra all
right all this if you're questioning I
don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the bluetooth's
coming to your house no awkward doctor's
appointments
no awkward doctor's visits it's all
online
bluetooth.com Thank Me Later what's up
guys hey um if you are watching this and
it's April 20th 4 20.
I'm gonna be hanging out at hardean
today
that's right put the flyer up The Rock
I'll be at hardeen um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Los Vegas Nevada now Hardy in
Las Vegas they are our family they'd
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so what y'all need to do
is go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas follow him on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're going to be
doing a lot of content in Vegas
live from hardeen they also just dropped
a tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope flag gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
get that hard eating whiff smells
amazing so look make sure you go to
hardine uh if you're in Vegas get in
that Uber get in that cab as soon as you
touch down say take me to hardine the
taxi drivers the Ubi drivers they know
exactly where it is because it's the
hottest spot in Vegas they go take you
straight there you're gonna tell them I
sent you they're gonna get you situated
real nicely all right Harding underscore
Las Vegas go show them some love go to
hardinglasvegas.com gotta give a shout
out to our oh geez my dogs had Odd Socks
baby they've been with us from
day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butthead socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead
drawski's bro
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta with some of these Big
Lebowski socks
and they just got Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg say 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview what's the best strip club
in Miami in your opinion oh man I mean
booby trap booby trap booby trap wild
Place booby trap I love booby and I
ain't gonna front the offices kind of
the office is lit if you go with the
right you gotta go right people because
small spots one way in one way out yeah
you know what I'm saying so you Gotta Be
You Gotta Know You Gotta Be You know
what has uh really good food is a taboo
they got a chef in there I don't know
who the chef is it's Tory Lanez well I
don't know how much he owns them oh yeah
yeah he had oh I've never been I never
visited her I've been there but booby
traps like the new like yeah that was
another spot that has some five Perry
Perry Wings
nah not g it was a spot it was Cocos
Cocos I don't know if y'all know if
you're in the yams you know what Coco's
is it's a smaller duck dog strip club
they got some wings that was so far what
do you think about tootsies
I'm not a tootsie person like the homies
like love sissies but I don't
um
like the massages on the first on the
floor like up at the top I don't they do
more than massages yeah they do a lot
more than massages but I don't I don't
really like that I don't it doesn't do
nothing for me for four hundred dollars
though yeah no they go crazy I walked in
on one of my homies oh yeah my fault my
fault icy number
you've never tricked off on a stripper
no I gotta ask no I mean no I haven't
let me not do it like no no uh I mean
yeah it like go crazy no but you know
like um
in Miami I've seen some I've seen some
grown men dive into some really uh
because when I with a girl like I'm
her to make her have a great
night I want her to be like yo you
the out of me like that
was incredible like why am I gonna pay
you to let me give you a good night you
know what I'm saying like you should be
paying me what I'm about to do to you
that's how I look at it so I'm not you
should be paying me yeah I mean that's
how like if I was that's my mind State
like I'm not I'm not I don't I don't
you're not I'm not trying to bust I got
a bus right yo let me let me go and get
that if I was a I get it I would
definitely pay so you can get out my
face
you know but for me it's more of a like
so like it's a it's a little mind thing
like okay so
I don't want to get into the intricacies
of this I don't care you get it whatever
you want to get it so like for you like
do you have like
okay you're obviously
you got the strap on like in the in the
drawer ready to go different sizes for
different chicks like oh now I don't
have different sizes for different
shapes you just got the like how does
how does how does a a masculine lesbian
woman pick this the go-to strap I only
got one straw you only got one one size
fits all okay I'm just curious no I'm
not like oh I got let me put this strap
on for her nah we don't have that like
literally got the main guy got the main
one okay I got the main one and like you
know sometimes I'll bring it sometimes I
don't like I'm not like a person who
gotta carry the strap like everywhere I
go like
I'm just I mean I don't know no I love
that I love these questions like I mean
just as a you can ask me I'm never
wondering this free game for the
homework because I'm like you know
because like you'll see like
but I was in Miami one weekend and I
don't know what was going on but it was
like a stud weekend do you know what
weekend I'm talking about in Miami yeah
sweetie shout out to um DJ dimples I was
in town during that uh for something
else and I was on South Beach and it was
just like a bunch of young Mas running
around it was crazy I was like damn
this is crazy I'm like what is
going on in Miami this weekend everyone
looks like Queen Latifah and set it off
oh my God shout out to Queen Latifah and
Senator so I was just I just wonder like
when it comes to like you know because
y'all be pulling some bad you
know what I'm saying like I just wonder
because women love women what the strap
situation is women love women yeah yeah
this is this is never going to change
like a woman just loves women how often
do you get a new strap
now I do change my strap two chains but
like I said every three months every six
months yeah it could be it depends on if
I'm a lot if I'm like going
crazy I gotta retire this one yeah yeah
yeah
but
but also also like sometimes you gotta
use I I'll use a condom on it like I'm
laughing so you put a condom on the
strand out of respect for her like I
don't know like yeah cause you don't
know yeah yeah out of respect out of
respect you know a lot of respect for
the uh you know for the straw yeah
laughing a disease my
all these out here hitting on so
you gotta be careful you know because
but but like honestly like yeah it's not
it's not like it's just like a dick I
feel like just be going in raw
and it was just which is crazy
especially in 2023 which is sick yeah
it's a crazy thing we'll just sit but
like yeah nice no that's what's up I
said I appreciate you for explaining
such things not easy anything bro listen
my hands a little sweaty anytime you
need some like advice about you want to
know what's going on
I'm just curious Hey listen come on so
now I know that that was sweetie weekend
yeah sweetie weekend yeah cause it was
wild it was wild now I get wild I'll be
seeing girl I'll be seeing some studs be
walking out with their strap I don't do
that like they be like literally having
their strap on like they got a dick when
they walking around I'm not I'm not I'm
not that masculine you know what I'm
saying I'm masculine but I'm not that
like you know like I'm not gonna do that
I'm not gonna have my just yeah I
get it well listen uh the new ep's out
yeah
um
shout out to them if they do that though
I respect whoever does that I'm just
saying Ah that's me likewise I would I
would respect that too if I saw somebody
walking around with that and they're
like I'd be like yo yeah respect she
hang it like I feel like Brittany
Greiner might walk around with that you
know what I'm saying no shout out to
Brittany shout out man she deserves to
do whatever she wants being locked up in
Russia for that Phoenix Mercury I'm from
Phoenix so okay Legend
um so yo go run up to EP you got a bunch
of music videos out
um and then hopefully this Diddy album
comes out soon that's your a r in yeah
and you're working on the album working
on the album I can't wait for the album
man I can't wait to even give you out a
title the title's so smooth before the
end of the year you'll have it out I'm
trying to add this out by like August
September oh so real soon I'm
really trying to like work on this like
heavy and then you're still writing
still writing still writing still going
crazy anything come out recently that
you could shout out uh
I did Chloe uh her new project okay pray
it away shout out to the black Zoo
project I did a song called night on the
last project called night ride home okay
yeah I know that last song I love that
last one of my favorite artists so he's
so good shout out to my boy black he's
incredible there it is we'll appreciate
you pulling up Jazzy my God thank you
there it is